so
um I wanted to go around
have you ever been cheated on and how
did you find out
yeah I've been cheated on
I've had two boyfriends and they've
cheated on me
I think the first time I found out was
through my friend she found some
messages and sent them to me and the
second time a video of my boyfriend
actually got put on YouTube
of him on FaceTime to another girl doing
not so good things
how did you I like how how was he filmed
like who filmed it it was like someone
scream recorded the FaceTime call and I
got a message on Instagram and this
woman basically said like if you don't
give me money I'm gonna post it I was
like go ahead post it I said if he's
cheating on me why I'm not gonna help
him yeah yeah is he is he famous why did
they put him on YouTube
I think she just wanted like attention
but it got taken down anyway so
what was he doing on there
well you know you know when you go on
FaceTime sometimes like guys gonna face
time to a girl and though you know well
you pulled out
he was having phone sex with this girl
oh what is it is he a girl or a shower
yeah
um so yeah I've been cheated on before
um once to my knowledge
um and basically it was a long time ago
but I found out two years later because
I started dating without knowing again
one of his friends and then his friend
told me oh by the way three years ago
crazy you're not with that guy no more
yeah
yeah it's crazy obviously by that time I
didn't care but what's the point maybe
yeah maybe if we will make him look
better or something yeah I mean it did
would you guys respect a man that does
that no way
Chase is not loyal I mean I won't even
respect a girl doing that do you get
what I mean like I'm not coming to you
as a woman no not even that like if me
if I if my friend cheated on a guy and
then he was then dating me I wouldn't be
talking about her especially at the time
if I didn't tell him why am I telling
him after you wouldn't really be dating
him anyway I wouldn't date him but just
say even if it wasn't yeah even if by
coincidence I didn't know that was her
man and he was to come in my life I
wouldn't then because if I didn't tell
him then why would I tell him now to get
by me no point fetching up the past yeah
I kind of wish he didn't because I just
got hurt for no reason basically but
he's already discharge it did you break
up with him immediately
um but I wasn't I wasn't with him anyway
oh like I found out three years later so
I wasn't even with him it was such a
weird one so yeah I guess it was good
that you found that later because yeah I
mean it's less heartbreaking but it
still hurts like oh okay then you need
to know yeah like I just I'd rather have
not known that's the truth I was fine
it is what is
okay that's crazy
um yes I have been cheated on before I
just had that instinct too when I said I
just want to free his phone I literally
just went on his phone and I saw
everything I needed to see when you see
who shall find in it yeah that's what a
guy told me a guy told me if you look at
any time you always find something you
have an issue with I don't think you
will I know but I just got handed the
phone in front of me it was right in
front of me oh damn so it's like I just
I was like oh
what did you what did you find
um
a lot of messages okay he was like what
are you doing for Valentine's Day
um
so you're going with that [ __ ] over
there okay have fun that was literally
how it was did you dump him right away
um or did you did you stay with him for
a little bit for how long
um it's always the way it works
for four more months and then did he
cheat again
that's always the way
um if you went through his phone and you
didn't find anything would you have told
him you went through his phone
the thing is so he just kind of like
gave me his phone and it was like on
open yeah that makes sense like all the
messages were right in front of me that
was God
so it's like
I don't know maybe I would have told him
I went through his phone okay like if
yeah okay go ahead
gosh my story is a bit long I don't know
how much time I've got are you can if
it's interesting go ahead yes
um yeah it's okay so basically
his cheating was never confirmed he's
always denied it even though I've got
substantial evidence to say that he's
cheated on me he will still deny it
um he so
at Uni there was three of us or four of
us that were friends there was three
guys and then me
um and then when I broke up with my
partner at the time I was only about 19
or something
um I started dating him he was like a
friend that obviously I'd known him for
about two years like homie Harbor yeah
yeah because me I like I like to be
connected to your mind to get what I
mean and he was he wasn't like the
friend didn't work out so you're like oh
there's his friend and then no no no no
no no so he was my friend so we were
almost he like made it out of the he
made out of the friend zone oh but but
he was friends with your ex too no no he
was all so we were just a uni friends we
were just a bunch of friends and then so
yes when I became single they all
approached me and I chose him oh okay
okay okay yeah but that you're there was
no connection with it yeah it was just I
was single for the first time and it was
just like okay cool
um so I was dating him we were together
for about I'll say two years and in
between that I found a few things but
he'll always deny it cool I then moved
into a property with one of our mutual
friends girlfriends so one of the guys
from the circle his girlfriend
and me and her live together they then
moved in with us because they were meant
to get their own property but it was
just like we might as well just like all
live in one place so it was that cool
everyone used to come to our house it
was like the uni little hot spot my
friend that was dating the girl
he went away so he went to his country
and he was there for some time and I
started noticing a different behavior in
her like her her pajamas started getting
shorter they started going out at the
same time or they'll try to stay in at
the same time and I thought this is
getting a bit awkward like
anyway she they then disappeared one day
at the same time she said she's going to
see her mum he said he's going to see
his mum and we had a group chat they're
not responding on anything you know at
the same time so I thought is it me or
like is this too much of a coincidence
anyway
um when I when I asked him well I said
to him there's definitely someone she's
cheating with because she's you know
dressing up a bit more she came home
that night and she was talking about
like you know she was talking about some
crazy stuff so I was messaging him like
oh I think I know like she's definitely
cheating but I think I know who really
feels like yeah try find out I was like
okay so obviously you know then the next
day he disappeared for the whole night
she disappeared for the whole night so I
thought nothing of it cool I went back
to the flat alone
um
the week later we had all our uni
friends come round and one of her Dopey
friends came and she didn't know how to
use just eat so she's taking her laptop
now to go and just eat
as she's gone on to put the postcode in
she obviously doesn't know how to use a
laptop so I said okay let me try use it
I've gone to click on the postcode and
it says cr0 and I'm thinking she doesn't
have no friends in Croydon like who the
hell where's she going in Croydon so
I've now memorized the postcode and I'm
not going to him like yo yo give me your
phone I think I know who she's shooting
with and he was like yeah yeah try it
try it like see what you know so I've
now gone and put in the postcode
uh oh sorry before I get there basically
when he came back from his night away we
had a massive argument he left the house
I went through his pocket and I saw a
receipt for Hallmark hotel right so
obviously he came back he explained that
he was at his mom's but he needed
um some time away from her so he just
booked a hotel for himself I said why
didn't tell me anyway yeah cool long
story short he needed some time alone so
as I've now gone to put the postcode on
his phone the pin drops at Hallmark
Hotel wow oh so they were together well
this is it so straight away in the whole
group of friends I've now confronted her
and I said how the hell do you know
Hallmark hotel and because he's such a
good Prof prolific liar he goes I made
her order me food
I said sorry and then he's now told me
that he's got her to order food because
he couldn't trust anyone else to order
food because everyone else would have
told me he's at the hotel
so long story short yeah I found that he
was cheating with my flatmate
and did you break up with him
no because he convinced me that it was
that wasn't did he really can like come
on no he can
you wanted to be convinced no no why
saying he convinced me I called my
friend straight away and I said listen
your girlfriend's a cheat blah blah blah
this is what's happened he then spoke to
her apparently she showed proof that
they were they called for the food or
what whatever so he then convinced me
that his girlfriend wasn't cheating on
him she he then made me feel bad that
I'm even making such a big allegation I
still said yeah I'm still moving out I'm
not gonna lie like I gave him my notice
um so yeah he convinced me that they
didn't do a thing so how long did you
stay with him after that a good two
years two more years and are you oh
shall be the most interesting part
um what made you switch like from being
convinced to not convinced I was never
not I was never fully not convinced okay
so yeah so I still have you said you
said he convinced you yeah he tried
committing to me so obviously I still
stayed there so okay this is where I'm a
little confused you were you were
convinced or you were not I was still
like because I thought you maybe found
more evidence later no I found more
evidence later oh okay I definitely
found more evidence so I know that he
definitely did but he still would deny
it okay okay yeah yeah okay what was
that interesting so what was interesting
is
um so a couple of years later now
university has happened and we've all
graduated you know she was a [ __ ] on
graduation cool
um we've all me and my friend we broke
up because he felt like we I broke up
the Friendship cool
um then a couple of years later I was at
home which like we were living together
and then I was going through
I was on laptop and we used to download
you know like we had LimeWire or
whatever then so you just download shows
and as I was going on um a show to watch
the profile a photo came up and it said
please insert USB and her name was a
show that we used to watch so I won't
say the show because obviously it was it
disclose who she is but it was she had
so I thought it's the show that he was
watching right it was on his recently
viewed so I've gone to click here and it
says oh please insert the USB
so he's always have USB on his keys so
I've now inserted the first one and it
wasn't showing so I'll inserted the
second one and it came up with a folder
and it had all her pictures oh wow
so I've now gone onto my computer to go
see what like what's on what else is on
there and there was no folders and like
no files and I was like this is so
confusing and I was I'm not tech savvy
like I don't do technology so I've had
to now go on Google find how to unhide
folders I've gone to unhired folders and
there was about 60 folders of girls
pictures that he must have been chatting
to over the time and he was saving them
wow
he just had a file of the white Bank in
it oh were they like naked explicit yeah
whatever like whatever folders he had
like so so when so when was that that
was that was the end of our relationship
okay that then it actually ended yeah
okay yeah then I found out that he was
actually then cheating on me with his ex
oh so that's what how many how many
girls total
a lot I I still wouldn't he'll still
deny but I wanted you with the weights
so so you found you found a picture like
a whole folder of naked girls multiple
pictures not even just naked the sun
might have been just oh okay innocent
ones right but it was a part of his
collection and he said and he said that
this is nothing yeah he told me that he
she only like the gold the flatmate only
sent him pictures because he was giving
her advice on what to wear I was like
what you got one like what do you mean
you're advising her but yeah that was It
was obviously you know um he tried lying
as much as he could okay and then that
was the end of the relationship yeah
yeah okay
was there wait wait wait actually was
there anything we missed in the story
okay so basically I just felt sorry I
just felt like you had more to say
so basically his girlfriend his ex at
the time I used to see messages from a
girl called s coming up and I had doubts
it was his ex right and he was like no
no no it's not anyway when I found that
them pictures he then said you know what
I can't do this anymore like I'm done
you're always doubting me I said yeah
because there's reasons cool then
obviously he broke up with me then the
next day I had taken the number s's
number and I called it the next day and
I said oh hey so and so is you know who
with you
and I heard him start laughing at the
background and he had a very specific
laugh so it confirmed that he was with
her but obviously she denied it she was
like why would I be with him but yeah so
so you kind of had like red flags like
all four years would you say
yeah pretty much yeah okay and I stayed
like a dumb girl yeah okay but the first
instance you caught him cheating you
stayed
well obviously I had the doubts over the
four years right yeah yeah yeah go ahead
um no I've never had an experience like
that
um well I don't know if a man's cheated
on me I don't know about it I don't
search but you know okay
you don't know no no it might have
happened but you just don't know I just
don't know I don't look for the thing is
with men if you look for it you'll find
it if you want to find it
um yeah I don't look for that kind of
thing so yeah as far as I know no but
maybe okay
um let's start here yeah um I reckon I
have I never really saw anything
in particular but I had very strong
convictions that I was and then you know
like when this is why I say sometimes
sorry yeah men like I'm provoked because
I I knew but then I'd ask him and then
sometimes he'd say no and then other
times he'd be like a yeah because you
know what I'm making food safe I'm like
no just tell me the truth it's fine
and he's like okay yeah and then in
other times when I do bring up he's like
I didn't say that I'm like yeah you did
so I never really found anything
properly but I just I really need you
think you wanna know
no you know what I can have the truth I
never ask questions if I can't handle
that answer but I will be ignorant I
will happily live ignorantly but I would
ask a question when I know that I can
handle the truth and I think it doesn't
matter what it is doesn't matter how bad
it is please always tell me the truth
yeah I don't care how bad it is yeah
yeah it's easier just to be truthful
waste like don't waste anybody's time
and I hate women like oh you can't
handle the truth and it's like no I can
handle the trend a lot better than you
lying having someone kind of handed the
truth though I think some times we
I think sometimes women say you can
handle the truth but you actually can't
because I think and I think that's why a
lot of guys would then like even like
each other because a lot of women will
actually just tell me and we'll talk
about it but when he then tells you the
truth it's now a whole argument it's a
whole thing you can't you don't you
don't have a proper conversation about
it which is why I love them lie about it
you know where a lot of girls go wrong
men will test whether they can be
truthful of you throughout the
relationship yeah and you don't Club
those little tests where you might say
something and see how you respond to it
it might not be a big thing but that
response tells us a lot about how you
behave yeah so when it comes to the big
things there's no way for them to tell
you anything no but you know what it is
the response she gives you when she
first finds out when she says she can
handle the truth is going to be far
better than when she finds out you've
lied to her because that's when she's
vandalizing your car do you get what I
mean if he gets quiet if he gets caught
the reactions are far worse so even if
she says she can handle it and she
reacts it's going to be a lot more
better than when she finds out that
you've lied on top of that absolutely
I've seen women with the same energy
can't even lie to you I'm like I get why
the cat the guy was scared but he's
still cheating in the first place
huh I don't think guys can handle the
truth any better no they can't they they
don't I will die oh you guys get so
bruised my immune system will shut down
the spot if we told you the truth about
all the things that like we thought when
you asked for our opinion we're dead
yeah I'm I'm on this whole day don't do
it I'll go I'll end up no school I'm
glad that you admit that
Eagles fragile serious as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible